all right so the first images of
Deadpool 3 have just released online and
alongside them we have a big plot leak
we of course know that Hugh Jackman's
returning his Wolverine but on top of
this there's several actors that are
coming back throughout this video I want
to go through the new images and also
talk about what's leaked about this
story full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want anything ruined then I highly
recommend that you turn off now please
hit the Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy
the video and also because I've got a
cold which it's just it's just a nice
nice hit the Thumbs Up Button now
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
Deadpool 3. now from what I've been told
we're actually going to get a bit of a
teaser for the next film a lot sooner
than you think Loki season 2 is right
around the corner and apparently this
will have a tease towards the film
coming next year it makes sense too as
Deadpool 3 is on the 2024 sleigh and we
know that it's gonna deal with the TVA
wow wow
wow Owen Wilson will reprise his role as
Mobius and the TVA are gonna play a big
role in the film now how it's going to
work is that this is going to time with
the time travel that we saw Deadpool
doing in his second movie the film
closed out with him traveling back in
time and this was in order to right the
wrongs of the past he visited Baby
Hitler stopped Ryan Reynolds from making
Green Lantern and also dropped in a
fixed Deadpool in X-Men Origins talking
to Wolverine they actually had a moment
that set up the basis of this film and
Deadpool basically said if I come back
and I want to do a third movie you're
gonna sign on for it you Trump
see a chump now that takes us into
Deadpool 3 which according to the leaks
will have the TVA arresting him for
messing with time travel as we know
they're very strict on timelines and
even though stuff's running wild at the
moment they're still keeping things in
check overseen by Kang I'm guessing he
may make a cameo in some form or another
as it has been said this entire phase is
built around him obviously though there
is stuff going on with Jonathan Magis
right now now so meth guess we're gonna
see anyway according to the leaks he's
gonna be arrested by the TVA and though
cable and Domino don't appear they do
get mentioned this is by Emma Karen who
in the film will apparently be playing a
judge similar to Ramona rensslayer
she'll relate Deadpool's crimes and stay
that they return cable to his original
time they will also confiscate the time
traveling technology and want to enlist
them for a job that's the only way to
get out of trouble according to the
leaks it's gonna be a similar sort of
thing to Loki where he acts as an agent
to sort things out from what's been
posted by insiders they're gonna make a
joke about how messy the X-Men timeline
is and Deadpool's gonna have to come in
and clean everything up it's a nice
little meta joke I think because yeah
that that universe is in a bit of a
state and it does make sense to do this
with the TVA now Deadpool's apparently
teamed up with an agent called Paradox
who Deadpool just calls Bob because his
name stupid working for the TVA he heads
out into the Multiverse which is where
we get a tie into this 616 now you might
have seen this week that Benedict
Cumberbatch said he was filming for a
Marvel movie this year and my guess is
that it's gonna be Deadpool he's
obviously been looking into the
Multiverse and we know from those within
it that's strange is the one causing
issues throughout it addicted to
dreamwalking strangers called several
incursions which have led to the death
of trillions I actually have a theater
don't ever have twins because it should
give you diseases all the time time
so in case you haven't read Secret Wars
what happens is that is that we learn
how the beyonders have set things up to
try and destroy the Multiverse now what
they did is that they made a person
called the molecule man and this is
someone who'd be the same in every
single reality molecule man had been
built by the Beyond this act like a bomb
and they detonate him at the same time
throughout every reality this would
cause all universes to die at the same
time and thus the entire Multiverse
would then be destroyed however Dr Doom
learned of this and we discovered that
he'd spent decades with his forces
killing molecule men throughout the
entire Multiverse now I'm bringing this
up is that I actually think Doctor
Strange might end up being the mcu's
version of it as he's the same person in
every reality whether it's what if or
the ones who meet in the Multiverse of
Madness every version of him is
identical this isn't the case with
characters like Loki and as we've seen
he's got alligator versions and so on
he's also constantly causing incursions
in dreamwalking as well and him being
this would mean that the character's
death could be one of the the major
things that comes from Secret Wars
guessing they're going to kill off some
of the older characters in that and and
Benedict lad's probably getting fed up
anyway instead which is just a little
too anyway when we last saw him he was
going with clear to the dark dimension
and I think they might tease what he's
doing now uh in the comics during the
time of incursions we also had something
else that they could be doing what do
you mean what do you what do you mean
basically there were two books created
by Jonathan Hickman and these ran side
by side in the lead-up to Secret Wars
one was the Avengers and the other was
the new Avengers with the ladder dealing
with the Illuminati the illumawati Now
The Avengers book was basically about
them going on missions and tackling the
big threats that seemed like they were
well destroying however the new Avengers
book was where the real fights were and
it centered around the Illuminati
investigating incursions keeping it
secret that they had to destroy worlds
they kept this stuff hidden from the
public eyes now what I'm bringing this
up is because we've met an Illuminati
like this and they showed up in the 838
now according to the leaks when the 616
runner died his Spirit then inhabited
the a3a Wonder this is something yet to
known as Quantum immortality and it's
actually a few that's well recorded in
physics it states that if the Multiverse
does exist then upon death your
Consciousness would instantly go to
another reality this is something that
they discussed in the TV show devs but
I'll give you a quick rundown in case
you don't know oh so say you had to
revolver and you decided that rather
than hitting the Thumbs Up Button you
were just gonna go and play Russian
Roulette well you'd put one bullet in
the garden and that would give you six
outcomes and the six branching realities
from that moment now in five of those
realities you'd pull the trigger and
live however in one you would die gotta
according to the theory though upon the
moment of your death your Consciousness
would immediately instead travel to one
of the realities where you didn't die
you wouldn't be aware of this and
wouldn't be able to go back to the
reality in which he just died because
you just died lots of physics he was
sexy sizzixy stuff but from what I
gather this is what happened with Wonder
after her death and Multiverse of
Madness however due to herriman's Powers
their way shoes and upon arriving on the
a38 she ripped the world apart thus the
a38's now been changed into a brand new
house of M world where Magneto rules
overall Ian McAllen is apparently
returning as the character and he'll be
the ruler of this world here mutants
will out of the humans and if you've
read the spin-off stories then you'll
know what life's like in the House of M
World we're not imprisoned or anything
but humans are constantly reminded that
they're human they never get to
subscribe to things and they're
basically dying out now according to the
leaks the majority of the X-Men here
will be played by the original Fox
Universe cast and their costume will
also be based heavily on the 90s designs
the film is apparently going to be used
as a swan song for the X-Men Universe
with a saying farewell to her before
elements are brought into the MCU now
according to the rumors Magneto's forces
will be trying to protect their world
from a group known as the human
Brotherhood this will be made up of
characters like Nick Fury Jimmy woo doe
Pinder and Pete from Deadpool 2 Zozo
sympathetic mutants like Colossus Yukio
megasonic teenage Warhead and lastly
Wolverine can we get some toast actually
posted tweet last night with Wolverine's
classic costume in it and this is
apparently what he will be Dawning for
the film however it will have sleeves
now Logan will apparently steal Bob's
TVA device and then he'll go back in
time to try and change history if you've
ever read Age of Ultron then you'll know
something similar happens in that and in
the book he's the one who changes time
anyway on his journey he's meant to come
across several different universes from
the past and this will reportedly also
lead into some big cameos now according
to the leaks Channing Tatum will return
his Gambit and in case you don't know he
was in talks to be the hero for years
but this never materialized I'll not
spoil a flash yet in case you haven't
seen it because not many people have but
that movie did something similar now
honestly I'm gonna be honest with you
now I kind of feel like the Multiverse
movies are all doing the same thing and
it's getting to the point where it's
sort of a bit kooky-cutter I will be
there day one but I don't know if the
Multiverse format is a bit played out
already hopefully by the time we get to
Secret Wars people are still invested
because yeah I don't know everything's a
bit too similar anyway I'll start with
my opinion on a film I haven't seen for
leaks that might not even be real but
according to them they eventually lead
up to the events of an alternate X-Men
Last Stand Here we learn wonders
alteration to the reality made it so
that Magneto won the day and it was from
this point that he took over attempting
to stop that Deadpool has a Last Stand
at the Golden Gate Bridge here he's
meant to bring in several versions of
Wolverine including the one from Logan
and even x-23 there's also going to be
different Deadpools with one apparently
being Ryan Reynolds in a wrexham shirt
come on you cops now the ending is kind
of foggy but it apparently closes out by
descending into chaos with Wonder being
depowered by the mutant cure she's
banished by the TVA and some of the
mutants are tossed into the MCU timeline
which is where they're going to become
quote unquote someone else's problem now
on top of this we also have a first look
at Deadpool's costume which was dropped
online yesterday really like the red and
I was saying to my editors it looks a
bit like the MCU version of Deadpool
it's pretty much exactly how he looked
in the comics especially during Civil
War and it definitely feels more fitting
with the vibe Marvel Studios go for in
addition to this we also have some other
rumored cameos for the film with both
Chris Evans and Ben Affleck apparently
being on set this has made people
theorize their reprise in their roles
from the fox movies and in case you
don't know the studio made both the
Fantastic Four and also Daredevil thus
people assume they're filling in the
roles of Matt Murdock and also the Human
Torch how about whether that happens
we're just gonna have to see
it's also been said that Robert Downey
Jr has been spotted on set as well
though people don't know if he was
acting or if he was just visiting so
yeah lots of things to talk about there
though and though we don't know whether
these leaks are 100 I have run them by
insiders who said they line up with what
they've heard we're still in early days
though so some of this stuff might
change but if you've checked out our
other leaked videos in the past then you
know what to expect some stuff right
some stuff off with the ending tending
to be the thing that the studios mess
about with the most in the case of Conor
Mania in the flash we actually got about
90 percent of it right with the endings
being the things that were ultimately
changed as we know they went back and
re-shot things namely the endings but we
do have set photos that confirm what
things were originally like either way
there's a lot to talk about here and
obviously I'd love to hear thoughts on
the leaks and what you want to see from
the film if you want to support the
channel for as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below and as a tank you'll get early
access to videos every week we also have
our merch store over at xeroedition.com
which sells lots of nerdy inspired
t-shirts hats and more you just launched
your secret Invasion slash Pulp Fiction
inspired t-shirt so if you want to head
over there and help us out then the
links in the description now if you want
something else to watch we've got a
video on screen right now going over
what's just happened in secret Invasion
every week we're going to be breaking
down the series so if you're enjoying it
then yeah definitely check us out
promise to not have a cold and without
the way yeah promise broken already but
uh yeah I'll see you next time you take
care yourself a piece